well I guess what I first discovered was
a love for it and that that was when I
was actually I was for almost five years
old and I'm from a very small town in
Windom Minnesota the southwest corner
and there was a woman that moved there
in 1965 and she had been astride pianist
and the classical pianist from Chicago
and when she came to town she was this
great pianist and the only reason she
moved to wyndham was that her husband
and son had both died of cancer within I
think like a month of each other or
something it was really tragic and her
only living family was this daughter and
Windham so she moved to town and my
parents heard about her and invited her
over for dinner and after dinner she
started to play and it was just I mean
we had this awful little you know sort
of spinet piano in our house but it was
like it was like in The Wizard of Oz
when it goes from black and white into
color you know my life changed at that
point and it was like her spirit just
went into the air and was just dancing I
mean I could see things you know beyond
in the music with her how her
personality was just came into the sound
and i said i want that i want to be her
and she had red hair and my hair was
really bright red back then and so it
was just like I want to be mrs. Butler
and so I begged my parents for lessons
and and maybe in in myself I recognize
that I had you know maybe a talent for
it but it were just an affinity for
sound
let's see I mean it was a variety of
things I mean classical music mainly
through my mother and my teacher my mom
used to play Chopin around the house a
lot and and so Chopin Ravel you know
Mozart every all the classical music not
so much modern classical although you
know maybe some Stravinsky later on and
Copeland I was a Copeland freak when I
was young and then I loved musical
theatre songs like Cole Porter you know
just standards Gershwin and you know
Lerner and Loewe and Rodgers and
Hammerstein that I was just crazy about
that and my piano teacher really you
know encouraged me to you know do piano
kind of stride arrangements of you know
American popular old American popular
song and so those were the main things
you know the jazz I wasn't really
conscious of what jazz was the only jazz
I knew about was kind of just old stride
piano you know playing and then
boogie-woogie which she also taught me
to play so you know it was an odd odd
way to begin
she really encouraged me my very first
lesson she was an amazing teacher and my
first lesson is it's funny how all
things go back to Evelyn Butler but my
first lesson she she did something where
she played a major triad and then she
sang bright the day and then she played
a minor triad and she sang dark the
night and she said everything in music
has a feeling and there's a reason
behind it you know it it comes through
music theory and I want you to
understand why everything you play
sounds and feels the way it does and
we're going to analyze every piece that
you ever play well of course when you
start out on piano your first pieces are
harmonically very simple melodically
simple so she started teaching me you
know a major triad the notes of the
scale you know simple things like 145
chord which is a very simple progression
and made me analyze my music and then it
kind of got me wanting to write music
myself because what I became interested
in more than the way I played the piece
as I loved playing music and you know
pretending I was Horowitz or something
even though I was pretty horrible
probably but what I love more than that
was discovering what these composers
wrote you know in and coming to lofty
conclusions that you know Chopin wasn't
good at writing endings and you know I
was I was sort of critiquing composers
that kind of a young age it was sort of
ridiculous and so I started writing
songs just simple songs for friends you
know and then giving them as gifts and
things like that and so it was just kind
of um it came because of the way she
taught me I think